[Music]
why don't you want kids
excuse me
i saw how you reacted earlier
i know what it's like when you're just
starting out and you think you have all
the time in the world
and you know you're not going to be so
young
forever have kids
then you'll be creating something
together this is all just
setting
[Music]
oh you do want them
[Music]
[Applause]
mother
[Music]
we spend all our time here i want to
make a paradise
she redid all of it every last detail
and she breathed life back into every
room
are you happy i love you
[Music]
please come in hello hello
he's a stranger we're just gonna let him
sleep in our house
[Music]
hello hello did you know he had a wife
[Music]
he has pictures of you and his luggage
what were you doing in their luggage
what do they want
god help you
[Music]
they've come here to see me
you're insane
all i'm trying to do is bring lunch into
this house
open the door to new people new ideas
i'm so sorry get out of my house
you give into giving again
[Music]
it's just never enough
[Music]
you